[Music]
when you think about starting University
freshers week might be top of the list
making new friends a new town or city
and yeah maybe the lectures too but then
there's the debt and there are big
changes to student finance in England
from this September if you're about to
start a degree paying back your loan is
going to cost you more with many having
to start paying back the loan sooner and
for a much longer period now the value
of a degree could help your earnings in
years to come but if you're paying off a
student loan for 40 years is uni still
worth it I'm Leah belletto and this is
the Sky News Daily we'll be talking to a
money expert who will run us through the
changes and we'll hear from an expert
who advises young people and parents
about their options when it comes to
finding a University Place
but first let's hear from Thea she's 17
and knee deep in revision notes for her
a-level exams but took a break to talk
to us Thea how are you feeling about
your exams my first exam is in a week uh
on Wednesday so I mean hopefully all
goes well but uh we'll see prepared as
you can be I bet eh yeah something along
those lines
um so do talk to me a bit about your
plans after school what kind of career
are you hoping to do are you looking to
go to university at the moment yeah I am
so I'm hoping to study Physics at Leeds
and I think in the long term I'd quite
like to join the Army or something along
those lines oh wow that sounds massively
impressive I know you've got so much on
your plate already with exams and you
know navigating that but have you given
the cost of University
much thought so far I mean yeah that's
obviously a big factor in University so
for me I have taken out a loan for uni
for the tuition fees obviously I think
that's about I think for leads it's
9250 a year and then for Swansea which
is my second choice uni I think it's
about the same so I've taken out a loan
for that and um I've also taken out a
maintenance loan I'm obviously quite
concerned about that and I know the
changes that have come so that's kind of
Weighing on me a little bit and thinking
about how much money actually goes into
it so where's your head at at the moment
then you're pretty determined that you
will go to university despite the costs
or does it weigh down on you heavily at
all it does definitely weigh on me
um I am of the idea that as soon as I go
to UNI I'm going to keep up with the job
that I have currently uh in a different
time of lifeguard so I can go and do
that at a different Center just so I can
keep myself coming on and over the past
couple years I've been saving up from my
job to like accommodate for uni and for
me I'm very lucky I'm in quite a
privileged position where you know my
parents can chip in every every now and
again if I need that help but I do know
people who don't have that privilege and
I think it's those sorts of people that
are going to need a lot more uh help
than me so for example I know a lot of
people just decide to stay at home
because they just like they don't have
the money to go and uh live away from
home but yeah it's definitely something
that's Weighing on my mind and something
that I it's very it's very stressful in
a time of extreme stress anyway
[Music]
those changes will impact hundreds of
thousands of students just like youthia
who are just about to start their
degrees but it wasn't always like this
Greg Marsh household Finance expert and
founder of money saving website
nows.co.uk is also with me hi Greg how
are you I'm well thanks and Greg did you
go to UNI I did some years ago now I
certainly did and you know enjoyed it a
lot had a student loan at the end of it
and celebrated very much when I finally
paid that off some years ago now but yes
I remember I remember opening a
celebratory bottle of wine when I
finally cleared the debt oh same here I
think mine was about 10 years ago I paid
it off and yeah there is that moment
where you feel like wow I've
accomplished that and it's finished but
look changes are coming for students
aren't they this September but first of
all can you run through
exactly how student loans work currently
yeah so when you go to university you
have two big costs the first big cost of
course is your tuition fees and the
second big cost is the cost of living
and the student loan scheme is intended
to help students Finance those costs
unless you've got very wealthy parents
and they're very generous most of us
have to dig into our own pockets for
that the student loan scheme allows you
to borrow money up to typically most
students when they graduate about 45
000 pounds or thereabouts for a
three-year degree to cover those living
costs and tuition fee costs but you then
have to pay that money back and you pay
that money back
and under the current scheme which is
about to change over up to 30 years and
under the new scheme it's a new plan
five scheme over 40 years but you only
pay it back over that long period of
time if you earn above a threshold and
then that critically means that people
who earn more or pay and pay their loans
back sooner and people who earn much
less may never pay back their loans or
pay back a smaller proportion off their
loan okay I've got yeah I'm up to date
but as we said changes are coming what
are those changes Greg well the big
change is that a graduate who finishes
uni age 21 will keep paying until
they're 61 which means they'll be making
payments for most of their working life
there's two other important changes in
the plan 5 scheme the first is that the
interest rate for those repayments is
lower so notionally it's less interest
every year however
the new students will start repaying at
a lower threshold
rather than that threshold being a
little over 27 000 pounds they'll be
start repaying at a lower threshold of
000 pounds so that means they'll be
paying more back every year on the same
income and analysts calculate that for a
typical student over the lifetime of
their loan they will pay a lot more in
total possibly about twice as much
and it's even more subtle than that
because higher income earning students
because of the lower interest rates will
actually end up paying less overall
but those on middle incomes lowering
income middle income earners will be hit
more by the changes so nurses and
teachers if they've got a university a
degree will end up having probably a
significantly higher cost of their
student loan so people will start paying
their loans back earlier but over a
longer period and you've touched on it
there these changes who will they most
impact then
well these changes will impact all
students from set to start at a
University degree from this September
onwards and all those people will see a
difference it's just that if you're a
higher income earner the difference
because the interest rate is lower and
you're paying back your loan faster you
may end up actually clearing your debt
relatively early in your working life
those who have lower incomes they'll be
above the threshold for having to pay
back their loan after a few years of
work but that loan is not going to go
away until they get to into their 60s
and even though the interest rate is
lower because the threshold is also
lower as a result someone for instance
on thirty thousand pounds will probably
end up paying something in the region of
about 450 pounds a year for interest
rather than 250 pounds the department
for Education says the reforms are
needed to give more value for money for
taxpayers it says it will mean more than
half of new borrowers will repay their
loans compared to the current rate of 20
percent Greg why now why the change is
being brought in now the cynic in me
would say that this is about the public
finances the long run savings for
taxpayers as a result of these changes
is something in the order of about
nearly two and a half billion pounds
according to the Institute of fiscal
studies so there is a very significant
Public Finance benefit to making a
change like this you might argue if you
were so minded that this change is more
likely to encourage students to select
degrees
that are going to lead to higher or hope
to lead to higher salaries over their
working life whether it will have that
effect I think that's for that's for
listeners to decide but I think those
are the two arguments in favor of this
clearly the arguments against this are
that it's going to be more money and for
longer and for many students
particularly those on middle incomes
it's it's not good news so really
shrinking the spending power of those
people along with all the other costs of
living pressures it's been described as
a tax would you agree it's a funny sort
of half tax half-debt thing it looks a
lot more like tax than like that but
when originally student loans were
introduced of course the intention was
to try not to manage them as attacks
from the perspective of the public
finances but to all intents and purposes
they're a bit like attacks because if
you don't earn more than that threshold
you never pay them back and when they
pay back their loan again more like a
tax than like debt it comes out of your
paycheck it's not money that you have to
pay at the end of the month from your
bank account so yes it has this quality
of being a bit tax like but many people
feel many students feel that they have
this weight on their back so to say that
it's just the tax I think yes it has tax
qualities but it also makes
psychologically many people feel it as
debt and that affects the way people
live and the way people think about
their uh their income
[Music]
I speak to a lot of young people and a
lot of my work is about
actually how this younger generation is
really up against it in many ways Lee
Elliott major is a professor of social
Mobility with the University of Exeter
and he spends a lot of time advising
young people on how to navigate the
complex higher education system Lee do
you think this will put people off going
to University and I wonder whether this
would have ever put you off I think it
would have me back we're talking 20
years ago now it's really hard isn't it
you all know this to put yourself back
in that you know 16 17 year old self
I think I didn't know hardly anything
about the higher education system at the
time I was on Social Security I was
living on my own if someone has said
rightly it's going to cost you 50 000.
pounds it is I think that would have cut
me off I think that's a real pity and
and things like
you know uh teachers and and nurses and
things like that you know I think we
could have designed the system better to
support those people in my view doing
the jobs that we should all value so I
do really worry about that that means to
me that I think we've got to work much
harder in the way we communicate these
um messages because I do think it's
worth it because you probably on average
will earn more than if you don't do a
degree that's so interesting you still
think University is a sensible
investment for students but I guess the
weight of debt if they're looking at it
in a debt sense um will be something
that they'll be carrying for the the
rest of their working lives do you think
some degrees some universities are
better value for money and should they
be looking at the University Prospect
differently with these changes in mind
so I think you've got to be really
careful in your choices I do think it is
a good investment but only if you make
uh do do the homework is there a work
placement that's part of the degree for
some people that would be you know a
good thing to look at is there sometimes
you know there's these amazing degrees
where you go abroad for a year as part
of that there are different types of
degree courses out there they're all
different they all probably some of them
are good at some things not so good at
others right and
um I do think
um you just need to look at degrees and
what are the links with the workplace
you know
um
I think some degrees are much better
that than others yeah but at the same
time I think these days there are really
good sort of apprenticeship options now
out there
um I call it the sort of dinner table
test you know if you're with a bunch of
mums and dads around the dinner table
this is the middle class thing this now
and someone says oh yeah my my
daughter's doing an apprenticeship I
think 20 years ago everyone would have
put their noses up there oh you know
that means they aren't doing so well I
don't think that's the case anymore I
think there's some really good
apprenticeships out there and and you I
think as a young person you need to
think about the other thing I'd say I do
think that you can take your time with
this you know and and maybe do go out
and get a job for a year or even and
then come back to it you know
the way the system works increasingly is
you can go and get a loan later and I
think that's a really good thing
um again with all the studies I do what
we're finding is
this is more anecdotes bracelet research
but my sense is people are younger for
their age than they were a generation
ago what do I mean by that I suspect you
and me were just
um a bit more mature in some ways
when we were 17 18 because we had to be
to be honest
um for all sorts of complex reasons I
just think young people now are just
slightly not particularly the covid
generation
um so you know I just I just fear that
they're making these big decisions quite
early on in their lives
so Lee what is your advice to students
now who might be worried about the costs
so I would say do your homework
have a look around ask the university
questions you know they get the money
for these uh courses
um I think it's quite right that you
should go and ask questions about what
what how many how many tutorials are
there what have the students done who
have graduated from that course
if you have time I would try and find a
graduate from that degree course that's
the best thing of all you know what was
it really like
um so I I would do lots of
um homework to
decide on which degree you do because
not every degree is the same and I think
we tend to think of universes as all the
same they're all different
and within universities there's some
really good courses and there's not
there's some that aren't so good so you
know
um really do your homework because this
is the one of the biggest decisions
you'll make not just because the money
because because of the way it will
change your life
Thea let's come back to you I mean aside
from
challenges that you have ahead the cost
of living and and paying for the course
are you excited about uni how are you
feeling about it I think the general
consensus amongst me and my Mates is
very positive you know we are excited to
go there but there is this kind of
looming thing of Financial and also
housing issues once we get there so I
have a couple friends going to
Manchester talking about applying for
accommodation who are very stressed out
about that and that sort of thing so I
think you know the general consensus
consensus is excitement but also there
is a lot of stress
my thanks to Thea Roland Lee Elliott
major Greg Marsh and to you for
listening to this episode of The Sky
News Daily with me Leah belletto this
episode was produced by Sydney peed the
editor is Philly Beaumont